دلع العنف على ارضيه الملعب
القيت الزجاجات من قبل المشجعين
وامتدت المعركه حتى غرف الملابس لقد فازت
المجره على البرازيل اربعه اهداف سكنت
شباك
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على معركه بيرن
المباراه التي وصفت بالاعمى في تاريخ
المونديال عام
1954 نظمت سويسرا بطوله كاس العالم وقتها
ولاول مره اوفر الاتحاد السويسري بثا
تلفزيونيا لنقل المونديال على الهواء
مباشره العالم باكمله كان يراقب هذا
المحفل الكروي الكبير المجموعه الاولى ضمت
كل من البرازيل يغزلاف يا فرنسا والمكسيك
البرازيل تاهلت كمتصدره لهذه المجموعه
بثلاث نقاط اما المجموعه الثانيه فضمت كل
من المجر المانيا الغربيه كوريا الجنوبيه
وتركيا
البرازيل واختها كان منتخبا رهيبا بقياده
ديد الساحر اما المجرى فراغ غياب بوشكاش
الى انه كان منتخبا قويا جدا وكان المرشح
الاول للفوز بلقب
المباراه بدات على ملعب بيرن وبدات معها
معركه ربع النهائي كانت عنيفه للغايه عراق
مبكر في دقائق الاولى
بهدف مبكر في الدقيقه الرابعه وساده القدس
يعمق جرح البرازيل بالهدف الثاني في
الدقيقه السابعه مع اخرج راقص السامبا عن
تركيزهم
قبل نهايه الشوط الاول تدخل البرازيليان
بين هيرو ونيلتون سانتوس بقوه على المجاري
جوزيفتوت يخرج مصابه باصابه جسيمه ويغيب
حتى نهايه البطوله
بدا الشوط الثاني وسرعان ما قدم منتخب
المجرى على امل البرازيليين في العوده
للمباراه هدف ثالث عبر ركله جزاء سددها لن
تسبقوه بعدها بخمس دقائق خلص المنتخب
البرازيل النتيجه ليتجدد العراق بين
الفريقين مره اخرى اللاعب البرازيلي باور
تدخل بقوه على بوجيكا الذي غادر للعلاج
وما ان عاد في الدقيقه الواحده والسبعين
حتى تدخل عليه البرازيلي نيلتون سانتوس
بشكل عنيف مره اخرى
ستعصب وجيك تبادل الركله ولا كماد فقرر
حكم اللقاء طردهما معا حتى ان الشرطه
تتدخلت وساءت اجواء المباراه
الجمهور حاول النزول لارضيه الملعب
لاشتباكات بين اللاعبين امتدت الى خارج
العشب الاخضر لدرجه انها وصلت الى غرف
الملابس والنفق المؤدي لها المباراه صنفت
الاعمى في المونديال فقد احتسب فيها 42
خطا نصفها تدخلات عنيفه وفيها ركله جزاء
وثلاث حالات طرده واربعه تحضيرات الكرت
الاصفر لم يكن قد ظهر بعد
هذه المواجهه عرفت فيما بعد بالمباراه
سيئه السمعه الجميع توقع عقوبات رادعه
بسبب هذه الاحداث العنيفه لكن الغريب في
الامر انه لم يتخذ اي من الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم او الاتحادين المجاري
والبرازيلي اي اجراءات عقابيه ضد اي لاعب
من الفريق